well speaking of family Bryce uh shared
this old photo so we're going to put
that look okay where are you there you
know what I don't even like really know
necessarily but you're winking at us oh
am I oh no you know what it is I'm like
I'm very sensitive to Sun so yes so it's
very likely that I just couldn't see
anything yeah but I my family um uh we
always go on road trips that's always
the thing that I would do kind of like
growing up and it would always be these
these road trips um and um uh no one
enjoy them except for my mother uh and
forced family fun yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was like the second thing like car door
was shut we knew like there was no
escaping for at least 6 and a half hours
and so just like did you bring the
bananas with you like it was like very
intense but um it was you know like
there were there were definitely
definitely a lot of great memories and
then and then there were a few weird
ones one time my parents were driving
from LA to euse and they left my
11-year-old brother in a Crispy Cream in
Los Angeles and it took them four hours
to figure it out and they arrived in
eane and four hours four hours yeah what
kind of therapy has this one been
through I know I know well actually
really good as a mother now I know it's
very home alone actually totally Home
Alone leaving the kid that was that was
reasonable that was
no no four hours four hours Crispy Cream
it's a nice place
toang 8 hours because my parents needed
to drive back to to get him and my mom
cried the entire time and they show up
and my you it's a little stereotypical
so I apologize if I offend anyone he was
surrounded by cops and they were all
eating Donuts together it's what it is
it was fine I mean we all eat donuts not
just cops they're good yeah especially
when you get there and they're warm I
mean I've
heard
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home